hello grammarians hello page hi david so
today we're going to be talking about
quotation marks what are they and what
do they do page finch we use quotation
marks to indicate when someone is
speaking
right so if we're writing dialogue
we can say
i like strawberry jam said
ladybuffington so that's one use of
quotation marks which is to to quote
direct dialogue or to quote from a
broader work
we can also use quotation marks for the
titles of things so paige if you
remember you can use underlines or
italics uh to indicate the title of
something big like like a book of poetry
or
an album of songs or a movie or a
television show
so paige for instance one of my favorite
albums is uh gentle giant's 1975 album
free hand okay but that's with italics
or not with italics or an underline in
this case since i'm writing it by hand
but track two on that record uh is
called on reflection
okay so we put quotes around
each individual song on the album right
so this is this is the album
and this is a single song
on it paige let's say you and jake wrote
a book of bread poetry okay yes right
that is something i would do and he
called it the yeast i can do
that is a great title thank you
right so
underline it
um
to indicate that that's the full title
so this is
the book
and then this book is made up of
individual poems so let's say you wrote
a poem in the book called uh
right do you
love me
sure why not so that's in quotes and
that indicates that this is a single
work or a single poem okay
also let me know when that book is
coming out because i'll buy your book of
poetry so it's not just songs and poems
right
but it's also
magazine and newspaper articles
tv episodes
really it's anything
that is smaller
than a larger work right it's something
like inside of a
of a larger thing like a collection or
right yeah an album uh so you know like
if if you were writing for a magazine or
a newspaper that newspaper's title you
know the
khan academy times would be
uh either italicized or underlined
but an article that you wrote for it
you know would would be
in quotes
i think that about does it for quotation
marks paige yeah uh david yep i think i
thought of a red poetry book name okay
what is it
loaves of grass
yup yup yup that's pretty good okay all
right putting it in there
that's quotation marks
you can learn anything
dave it out page out loads of grass